on va tenter interview jacques demy en
baisse la lumière katrina t'as vu
jacques demy il faut répondre en
chantant est ce que vous êtes en
reprendre sept péchés capitaux c'est
plus sympa ce que vous êtes avare quand
il faut dépenser pour un nouveau rideau
je regarde de ma poche et n'y voit point
le fond les quelques sous sont là et là
il me reproche que le rideau peut bien
rester là encore dix ans
gentiment est ce que vous êtes soliris
ça m'arrive
oui et oui envieuse info je regrette ce
que je n'ai pas ça m'arrête au lieu
d'aller nord vers ce qui me tend les
bras je m'accroche à ça
cette gourmande
le mal
non
là
c'est merveilleux la gourmandise est
quoi qu'on en dise
y'a qu'ça kim gris et on signale gilles
carrez ce besoin de rien envie de toi ça